yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing plus from knowing that's a good
opponent seven point five out of eight
that sounds good so what do we get Kings
Indian no yeah some modern defenseman my
transpose yeah against this h4 h5 has a
good reputation it is that depends a bit
on how he plays now aged six is what
they normally do it's a little bit
surprising that he thinks there's a
choice by far the critical move my you
can play you can play there should be
three maybe or something but each form
yeah this is difficult for black to play
because now it's hard to play at five
almost impossible to play a five you
would weaken yourself quite a bit yeah
so Knight to g5 immediately on Norton's
is the thing I'm going to do it right
away discouraging at five and you never
know when a good day maybe Bishop takes
h5 will work I cannot do it immediately
and the bishop sec what I want now after
something like yeah like this Bishop
takes h5 now it's not really working on
it he can go probably f6 attacking to
two minor pieces
yeah interesting as is he going to go f6
now next move I cannot go 36
I can take c5 and then 96 but that
doesn't help really look that's not not
too bright I thought have six okay night
on g5 is annoying it's an annoying piece
now i can think of taking actually yeah
this is an interesting move we can take
and play for d6 and stuff them to
prevent maybe Luke a six is an idea who
basics org f6 it's a similar similar IDM
let's see you back in 36 excellent
interesting try to use the D file Quincy
3 also is now an idea sometimes ninja
five
35 is some hanging MGR efile is hanging
visit yeah it's not like it's not the
most attractive pawn to take and maybe
my queen gets trapped if i take it so i
need to be cautious them the main point
of quincy 30 ever is 96 anyway whoa what
are you doing over there yeah okay
that's some of you playing anyway i hope
the empty seven next Queen somewhere cc8
Mary and then I get to take on c7 with
g7 and then Ted I don't I can actually
take c7 Queen to a group d 7 but that
move immediately looks a bit better so
just rogue shakes or org t1 threatening
97
you make that looks interesting maybe
you have some tech city like 97 this and
97's 94 I can also take with this group
137 cannot be all that terrible
how do we how do we win this position
yeah just take on b7 i don't know i'm a
bit behind timewise so would be eight
threatened or c5 is strongly knows he
files another threat yeah but ok clean
be 55 things like that get very tempting
to check
no that doesn't work that's a pin blank
Rhiannon's dallas cuff them all of
something that that bakes breakthrough
in the middle I don't know I'm i really
don't know it's complicated yeah h5 is
some probably somewhat questionable as
it is difficult to get an f5 they
normally play h6 in this position when
there are a couple of ideas so you can
go age 5 or d5 first this is this is
something that has been tried one also
on this variation f5 and then g4 there
there are a couple of things that have
been tested and this is not easy for
black because you always have those
weaknesses and difficult to get rid of
yeah i think this was was interesting
and audi six is a problem the knight on
d5 is extremely strong and you push with
F 60 s d6 if it would somehow have lie
to the 6mm in this building don't get it
played and g3 interesting by the engine
but ok I'm reason to be sure that this
is not bad c6 know that didn't I think
didn't think of that yeah but going back
is funnier yes sometimes have this idea
we played this 123 yeah and and now it
gets it gets really o.o Queen a3 is
strong I just wind upon haha okay no I
didn't see that one I was happy with 96
really but yeah okay if you just will
see 5 then
yeah then it gets really really good I
can yeah it's good but not not winning
probably so this is this rook takes I
know I played this one group c 7 also
was possible but i wanted 97 in the mix
like this this is this yeah and okay it
must be good for white but the other
thing probably was that i am alright
still still a disaster really see 5 in
queen bee 5k and yeah you're already
losing actually didn't see that that I
were taking this rope I was just
thinking okay c5 is probably correct
that didn't didn't even see that the
rope was saying this is why I was
surprised that he played this move like
what's not attique but ok the book was
hanging some okay yes thanks